[Music]
it was announced yesterday by the
Mexican government that they have
finally captured and arrested Miguel
Morales okay that's the leader of the
Zeta cartel one of the most feared drug
gangs in the country now he was arrested
with two accomplices and that means
ladies and gentlemen there's now a major
power vacuum and some of the lower-level
cartel members have had to step up to
sort of fill the hole well frankly I
think they're starting to scrape the
bottom of the barrel with some of these
new cartel guys check it out guys like
Vincent a fanny pack
Gutierrez Pablo spot treatment Korres
Eduardo too many mustaches Alvarez
Hector tiny gun Morales it hasn't
affected his attitude at all Esteban I
can smuggle almost anything Perez
Manny used to model for a popular brand
of hot sauce Dominguez one keeps
accidentally CC'ing the DEA kostina
Hector obsessed with cosplay Sandoval
Tony allergic to cocaine Ortega and
finally Miguel clearly an undercover DEA
agent Sanchez
[Applause]
[Music]